video of the year video of the year
okay
are you okay now because you put on a
performance tonight
it has been so talked about back here oh
my god oh my god i worked so hard for
his performance and i'm just glad people
like it you know my video of the year
of the year video of the year um and can
i tell you a little knowledge you are so
on point right now you still don't have
a shirt on at least you got some pants
and a jacket on now yeah you know i got
to try to dress up a little bit you know
no shirts though no shirts no let's get
rid of those yeah
that's more laundry i mean you have time
who wants more laundry it's like for the
birds
not for little knives not for me you
know what it is for me september 17th my
new album ontario yeah baby he's having
a baby maybe montero is very much still
here i'm sucking in my stomach right now
uh-huh you know you got your spanx on
yeah
spanx i got two different grills in
right now i can't even handle you right
now you are just feeling
next level right now i'm feeling like
i'm on cloud like 179
000 million
google
what are you going to do tonight to
celebrate bed i'm going to have a great
time with my brothers and my friends
and you know just celebrate and live in
this moment about right now right now is
what matters
yes oh my god i'm so thankful i'm so
thankful am i going to see you the matte
gala tomorrow night
all right what you going to be serving
up honey we're going to give y'all
something it's only a week it's going to
be a great week
it's going to be a week i cannot wait
look we're going to look back at this
clip it's going to be a week it's going
to be a week yes this is not a moment
baby this is a week baby
[Music]